all righty then we're gonna talk about
Sonic the Hedgehog excited that this
movie is finally out Jon wearing his
Nintendo shirt I'm still dressed sort of
like dusty from stranger things cuz we
just shot a reaction to that
anywho the highly anticipated film
highly talked about let's put it like
that IMDB has the plot description like
this after discovering a small blue fast
hedgehog a small town police officer
must help it defeat an evil genius who
wants to do experiments on it I'm seeing
a lot of different articles just
headlines I haven't actually read or
listened to any reviews yet they keep
coming out along the lines of Sonic is
actually better than I thought they did
it they made a great Sonic movie and a
lot of people are still underwhelmed to
me it really just boils down to this
experience what is your standard that
you expect from a film that is targeted
towards families my basic thought on
this was it feels like a 90s movie I
would have grown up watching the game
came out and what 91 won yeah it was the
first I could see the filmmakers going
let's make this like a 90s movie but
here's the thing
I couldn't truly tell if it was intended
to be that way or not and that's sort of
where the line kind of falls for me on
this because I did have fun for a good
amount of it there was a good amount
work I was kind of bored but there's
also a good amount where I really did
enjoy a lot of it weirdly the the
character that I actually enjoyed the
most is everyone's raving about Jim
Carrey and don't get me wrong Jim Carrey
is really good in this film what I liked
about what Jim Carrey did is dr.
Robotnik was he actually made a
character out of it this could have
easily been the case of let's get Jim
Carrey in the role let's just have him
do his Jim Carrey thing and let him let
loose and that's about as far as it goes
weirdly there are times were didn't
think I'd say this for dr. Robotnik he
brings a certain layer of gravitas to
certain scenes in this film or you could
really feel the characters upbringing is
history some credit goes to the writing
of course but I really thought Jim
Carrey did a really good job here this
is harkening back a little bit more
towards the early days of Jim I call him
Jim sometimes just Jake the early days
because sometimes when you
Carrie does sort of these hyperkinetic
manic performances like we grew up
watching him do he can feel forced this
one actually felt a lot more natural and
so I was happy about that that being
said my favorite character was actually
James Marsden and this yeah I thought he
struck the right balance he really knew
what film he was in a big part of what
made a lot of the scenes with sonic feel
believable was his performance now I
don't know the behind the scenes here
it's like of course we are aware that
there was the animation that pissed off
all the fans and then they went back and
redid it to make him look a lot more
like the video game Sonic the Hedgehog
character and I thought what made a lot
of those scenes feel very believable was
the way James Marcin interacted with
this character who was definitely not
there on set yeah
hey that's reaction shots and things
like that I mean and he does a lot just
naturally in his performance people
underestimate the power of the reaction
to sell you know an effect or whatever
and yeah especially when James Marsden
finally truly enters the plot everything
gets a little bit better and yeah sonic
himself gets a lot more believable just
in the world Ben Schwartz is doing the
voice-over for Sonic I thought he did a
really good job voicing the character
Sonic was adorable he was cute at times
they really emphasize how lonely of a
character he is and that's something I
appreciate about the movie this could
have easily been to put a blood just a
simple cash grab even though I'm kind of
just settling on a point of it was fun
who's about what I expected in fact a
little bit better than what I expected
if you watch our reaction to the second
trailer I was like yeah the the design
does look better but we still don't know
if it's gonna be a terrible film or not
like it doesn't matter if you make the
design better the the film itself could
probably be really awful still and it
wasn't there's a middle chunk because
this film turns into a road trip buddy
comedy movie and there are times where I
felt it was a little bit meandering and
a little bit unnecessary but like I said
at the very top of this it's the
standard you expect from a family film
some people might go there are some
great family films that are truly just
amazing films so why should the quality
standard of expectation dip just because
this film is targeted audiences and to
each their own subjective one side of me
is this could have been a lot better
it's could have had written so much
better I wasn't a big fan of the fur
acted this movie it was really when the
plot started kicking in when Sonic and
James Marston are actually interacting
one another when the film really started
click with me Jim Carrey and James
Marston start to interact with each
other that started getting really good
the thing that I felt was the missing
ingredient regardless of the standard
discussion was there could have been
more of a sense of wonder with this
fantastical story that they're telling
here that was the main missing
ingredient for me but overall yeah I
mean I feel like Sonic fans will
probably be pleased you know I mean
especially if you grew up on the cartoon
to which I've seen episodes of the
different cartoons I haven't really
grown up on them more the video games
for me but yeah I mean as a
representation of Sonic and as one of
these films that seeks to put a
character from a fantasy world into the
real world I feel like I've seen that go
a lot worse than this and Sonic wound up
to me being kind of both the movie I
hoped it could be and hoped it wouldn't
be or was afraid it would be yeah it
kind of straddles that line because I
think at some point everything in this
movie works to a degree and then at some
points it also doesn't so it was kind of
a hit and miss experience I agree that
it could have used a bit more wonder and
a bit more consistent urgency because
the road trip elements do start to
affect the plot in ways where you just
start to ask why are they doing this
when like they're being hunted down by a
brilliant no robot toting scientists
yeah the relationship between James
Marsden and Sonic is really dear by the
end of it Sonic can get a little
aggravating at times to be honest yes so
high energy and so there are times worse
the only character that actually would
kind of annoy me was Sonic but that's
not to say there were plenty of times
where I still felt endeared by the
character I did find him very charming
it's kind of like that complaint that
I've heard the line that's written with
Harley Quinn and birds-of-prey weirdly I
heard this is awesome you hear about
those hilarious tweets people like birds
of prey fans talking mad smack on Sonic
support came out some people took it
like as a serious protest but I just
thought they were really funny if you
guys haven't seen those tweets they're
so freaking funny the sonic design while
I think it's so much better looking than
the original design I was kind of pulled
in and out especially in the first half
the design of sonic never really
when did with the environment it never
felt like real to me it's like when you
can get lost in the movie and you just
kind of get you kind of like a Roger
Rabbit vibe or a spacejam vibe when you
just like settle into it you go along
with it you you you buy it there's a lot
in the especially in the first actor I'm
like I don't feel like this dis
character is real yeah it kind of had
that quality to me the goosebumps
they're animation for that first movie
was done by like Sony Pictures animation
so they have this animated character
type quality to them and I feel like
that's kind of what happened here even
detective Pikachu has some of that where
you're so used to seeing them animated a
certain way so that when they come 3d
and you know they're all CG sometimes it
is kind of hard to lose them into the
reality of what's going on especially
because Sonic is for the most part the
only thing like that on screen for I
don't know how long it'll take everybody
to get used to the effect ultimately I
think where it needs to succeed it does
and then yeah it's the question of like
how much do you forgive because there
are lots of like plot threads that get
dropped or things that you can think
about and going yeah did they just
forget completely it was also
exceptionally cliche it's very
straightforward but there's also
throughout it wasn't like I started
laughing and then I stopped it was like
permanently there were times throughout
this whole movie were the movie would
surprise me with something that I
genuinely thought was really funny
it does have some genuine good jokes
good bits good moments good action good
acting the action was cool there are
sequences that all that are more of a
courtier version of the Quicksilver
sequences and Days of Future past and
apocalypse it's like we've seen that
exact kind of sequence done in those
movies but they take a much more
childish approach yeah antics of what he
does them in terms of Jim Carrey I
thought he was a lot of fun too there is
I feel like a decent amount of padding
in this movie with just like sonic or
Robotnik related hygiene yes of some
kind and with Jim Carrey he he is the
one element of this movie it's like hip
Robotnik he is dr. Robotnik like in the
cartoons and stuff in the video games
he's the loud you know egotistical
scientist guy he's like Robotnik ish for
most of the movie then I think the thing
that happens with Jim Carrey
specifically there's a lot of great
scenes with him especially when he's
interacting just one on one with
character
and then there are these moments where
they're like do Jim Carrey things and
don't seem like what dr. Robotnik would
do let's just do a whole scene where
you're dancing dancing doing Jim Carrey
goofy body language stuff yeah I feel
like that works for an audience if you
loved Jim Carrey growing up and I did he
was one of my heroes personally I love
Jim Carrey growing up but I always root
for the guy I would still get pulled out
and be aware like this is only working
for me because I grew up on Jim Carrey
but if you're not a big Jim Carrey fan
this is probably just annoying yeah
doesn't make any sense why he's doing
this
yeah this character yeah I kind of
thought like this movies felt a little
torn between PG and pg-13 partly because
you know Sonic's cute and cuddly and
they want to bring the kids in but also
everybody who grew up on this game is in
their 20s or 30s now at least so uh you
know some of it did also feel like it
was straddling that line as well if
you're just in for like a pretty fun
sonic movie I think it gets that you
know it could have been a lot worse
yeah it's found what I expected it's fun
it's fine yeah bullet dodged a bullet
and probably not you know worth all that
controversy I'm not sugarcoating I'm not
like people get you mad at us we love
birds of prey if you want to go have a
fun time and you care at all about Sonic
it's well what do you guys think of
Sonic leave your thoughts down below do
you want them to start up that Sega
universe that they're opening logo was
clearly hinting either they want to
develop subscribe click that
notification belly get notified never
got a new YouTube video up and hey let's
end this with Derek Mitchell has been
having a great year so far
apparently I know last year was rough
for him this year he's saying
everything's been going great his job is
doing wonderful it looks like his life
has been on a speedy adventure I was
just like I was like going through this
Cowan who is the most like the James
Marston on the shout out list right now
and it's definitely Derek Mitchell I
mean this guy was an uber lyft driver
for quite some time so I can see him
hitting the road one day with a Sonic
the Hedgehog white character having a
ball explore in life create a bucket
list Derek and I hope you started
knocking all them off as soon as
possible
man your phone's gonna be ringing off
the hook when you step into those James
boys dinner shoes right so crack your
knuckles and you know get out of the
shadow of everyone around you and just
hit the road tails
[Music]